sous la pression de la rue les
événements donc se précipitent en
allemagne de l'est ce matin la vieille
garde du parti communiste de rda a sauté
en bloc et il faut d'urgence les gones
krems trouve des idées neuves et des
hommes crédibles catherine alors pour
les idées neuves il faut attendre
quelques jours encore et pour les hommes
crédibles c'est déjà fait et s'appellera
ce mode rohff il est pressenti pour
devenir le premier ministre de rda il
symbolise le courant réformateur anne
groix
hans modrow 61 ans chef du s&ed du
district de dresde et futur premier
ministre de la rda avec la nomination de
ce fils d'ouvrier docteur en sciences
économiques
c'est tout un symbole qui fait son
entrée au bureau politique et au
gouvernement fervent partisan de la
glace note que de la pérestroïka hans
modrow a tenté d'amorcer un dialogue
difficile avec les manifestants de
dresde et le mois d'octobre un dialogue
que ce réformateur devrait intensifier
la tête du gouvernement en le proposant
comme premier ministre le comité central
du parti communiste ne s'y est pas
trompé l'heure n'est plus aux demi
mesures de réforme un seul des 157
membres du comité a voté contre monroe
il y a deux ans ou l'hérault necker il
avait fait l'unanimité contre lui mais
désormais la vieille garde la plus
droite de parole après la démission en
bloc ce matin du bureau politique
proposé par egon krenz le numéro un
allemand n'a pas ménagé les anciens
dirigeants de la rda il les a rendus
responsables de la situation extrêmement
difficile du pays une critique sévère
adressée implicitement à erich honecker
pour harmoniser les discours et les
actes comme il l'a promis egon krenz
dispose maintenant de 109 5 nouveaux
font leur entrée dans le bureau
politique constitué de onze membres
parmi eux hans modrow bien sûr mais
également le réformateur wenger
schabowski chef du s&ed de berlin est
une nouvelle équipe décidée à agir vite
et bien ce soir higuain craintes annoncé
la prochaine l'égalisation
mouvement politique